have you ever wondered why there is so
much confusion in the world today on who
christ really is find out on this
episode of
led live
light exposing darkness welcome back to
another led live show
today we're actually going to talk about
my favorite subject
christ and you know what there
is so much confusion in the world right
now on who christ is it seems like
they've got movies coming out they've
got you know just
confusion on this topic so we're going
to try to wade through this and get to
the bottom of it but before we do
we want to thank you viewers for
constantly tuning in and watching
our show if you're new to this channel
check us out we got a lot of very
interesting topics we like to take
relevant topics that are going on in our
world today and filter them
through the lens of the bible so that
you can kind of begin to navigate
a lot of this confusion and of course
the truth really comes from the bible so
if that's your thing and you want to
find out more
about how do you get to know to the
bottom of truth
then stay tuned we're gonna discuss that
on this show here
thank you so much for our patreon donors
for constantly donating to our ministry
and helping us
create content you are such a blessing
to us and you've allowed us
to bless other people so thank you so
much and we've got a lot of cool
ways that you can support our ministry
as well not just patreon but if you buy
t-shirts we got a lot of really cool
t-shirt designs
yes every one of us are actually wearing
one of our t-shirts which is
i think maybe a first time yeah usually
there's one guy trying to support
you know adidas or something like that
but you know
we're um we're really uh trying to
share our witness and that's kind of why
we like the t-shirt thing
wear your witness get out there check
out our t-shirts you'll see the link in
the description below or you can go to
our website hey youtube
what is love
[Music]
so today in five minutes or less i'm
gonna take you through what i believe
christian love really looks like
all right before we get into this we
want to introduce you
david privitera is actually here with us
again on the show thank you for coming
on
again yeah today we're going to get into
a topic about
christ which is really cool so tell us a
little bit about this topic
sure um so this this is specifically
about
christ as he is and uh
for a christian for somebody who who
grew up in the faith or is new to the
faith and
knows christ through the scriptures um
you know we we sometimes have a
a bias to only seeing him that way but
there are there are other ways that that
people
outside of christianity or even inside
christianity
see christ and it's not necessarily
always to to
to how we see him or how we perceive him
uh and so i wanted to get into to this
topic today
as it relates to how society how how we
are
are being shown his image
by the by the outside world so we kind
of cover a little bit of this type of a
topic with some of our
videos exposes on different uh hollywood
movies that have portrayed christ
because
um especially in our documentary that we
did on superheroes
a lot of superheroes have christ-like
attributes so
people always say well what's wrong with
superman if he's like if he's just like
jesus and you're watching this story
about
you know jesus and it's just an allegory
what's wrong with that
but the real problem i think and just
distilling this down without knowing
exactly what you're going to say here um
you know the problem is really a
misunderstanding of who christ
is could be potentially setting you up
for the false christ when he does come
right
so it's very important this is a very
important topic
to understand and i'm sure as we we get
into this
um you know we're going to see a little
bit of that right and the differences
can be found even within the church
depending on which denomination you're
part of and the doctrines your
denomination holds you kind of
fit christ to that instead of looking at
the christ in the bible and taking it
how he was how he is so that yeah it
would be great to
identify who christ really is so
um does anybody here believe that we are
living in the end times
absolutely what are some things going on
that that you would say oh this this
this really fits into
prophecy this really fits into what what
the scriptures have foretold
uh where where are we today matthew
24 24. thank you where christ is just
listing out what will happen
and times one of them is uh natural
disasters and we see them intense
intensifying every season records
breaking
one after the other yep that's one of
them and the frequency
happening more frequently closer
together i mean i think wasn't there
just a
a a volcano that exploded in your
country that's right
it's now getting so frequent do you feel
like you're kind of numb to it yeah
like when she showed me that that oh wow
there's a volcano blowing up in my
country and then it was just like oh
okay well
moving on you know what i mean like it's
like now it's not such a
wow shocker to us because we're just
dealing with this all the time
and in politics um i mean granted these
things have been happening
all the time but now it's like in
people's faces more frequently there's
more conversations happening
pestilences shortages
many will grow cold yeah that's right
so yeah absolutely so matthew 24 and
that's that's
a great example um so the disciples they
were on on the mount of olives and the
disciples came to him privately
uh this is from matthew 24 uh verse 3.
they said tell us when when will this
happen
and what will be the sign of your coming
because
because jesus said do you do you see all
these things truly i tell you not one
stone
here will be left upon another every one
will be thrown down
so he was speaking of the destruction of
jerusalem but also in
in pro in prophetic words he was
speaking to
um the end times and this the
destruction of the world
um so so much of of jesus's life
um was was very apparent or is very
parallel
to how we are living today how how um
how our relatives lived long ago and
and really where where we are in the end
times
very parallel so so he answers them and
says
watch out that no one deceives you for
many will come
in my name claiming i am the messiah
and will deceive many you will hear of
wars and rumors of wars
you know how how many times have have we
heard of wars and rumors of wars
throughout the millennia um nation will
rise
against nation you will have famines
there will be earthquakes
in various places the king james version
says diverse places i
really like how it says that all of
these things are the beginning of birth
pains
really what we're seeing today is
all of this happening simultaneously
right
so there have been famines before
uh in in remote places in the world
there there have been wars
there have been diseases and pestilence
uh earthquakes obviously
but we are seeing this at an alarming
rate
all at the same time simultaneously
he says then you will be handed over and
persecuted
and put to get put to death and be hated
by all nations because of me
at that time many will turn away turn
away from the faith
and they will betray and hate each other
and many false prophets will appear
and deceive many people
and so you know we we're getting into
these uh these times of
of false prophets we're getting into
these times of
um major
pastors you know on on tv on on the tv
screen and
and they've got these mega churches and
and i'm not i don't want to you know
single out or or call out members of the
church these churches necessarily
but but people that may be listening to
a message that isn't scriptural or or
isn't
based on doctrine of god
um i also in in some of my some of my
research
um in the past year or two i downloaded
some
uh some content some some articles um
because i was hearing this this common
phrase called
christ consciousness and um
and i started doing a little bit of
research on that
but i'm curious so so so you kind of
perked up to
that what what what what do you know
about it and and have heard about it and
it's like trying to be like christ's
thing
that's my understanding like we are our
own god
yeah realizing that you are literally
divine and um i think the person that
really
popularized that idea or that i remember
first hearing about it was from oprah
winfrey
and um kind of her work yeah her work
with eckhart tolle
um that really they kept kind of
hammering at this like you know you
you just need to awaken that you you
actually are
are like like jesus my simple
understanding of it is
basically jesus got to a esoteric
understanding of who he was and that's
why he became the person that he was
and that we can achieve that same sort
of thing which i think
kind of sounds like the tree and
knowledge of good and evil if you ask me
but
you know it's like yeah we're seeing a
lot of um
a lot of that that that esoteric
uh activity um in society today where
where we're unlocking
you know the the third opening the third
eye unlocking
unlocking the pineal gland um and
and achieving the divinity within us um
kind of goes back to when when satan um
you know tempted attempted man the first
time and
and offered that that forbidden fruit
and said take this and you will be
as gods uh you you will be awakened you
know
your eyes will be open so um
so in that uh uh research and just did
some searching around on on christ
consciousness and i and i found
a um about a website called the loosest
trust
um i'm not gonna go super detailed on
on the organization necessarily or or
or the or the background of everything
but i i
found an article that i thought was
really interesting because it was called
christ as he is um
and the lucius trust is it's a
non-profit organization
so i so i downloaded this article called
christ as he is and i was i was
shocked uh at some of what i read
uh some of the content that's that's
within this article
it was actually printed in
another one of their publications
quarterly called the beacon
in november of 1981 i believe there that
it went through some revisions
or another reprint in 1998
i downloaded this last year in october
and uh just a few snippets here so
so from the beginning he is coming to
establish the principles and values
including the technique on which life
must be based during the aquarian
age and to encourage the present
incipient trends
towards right relationships leading to
peace on earth
due to unfold in the coming 2000 year
cycle wait sorry can i have a little bit
of context so this is
this trust and they're talking about
jesus christ is this the second coming
correctly okay and they're saying that
this is how he will be coming
and when they're saying the christ
so they're they're not they're not
naming him
so specific as jesus okay and as as i've
gone through some of some of this
article and a few other articles on
on the site um there are a few that do
say jesus but
but yeah this one in particular as as i
was reading it i was i was looking for
well is this jesus christ you know what
christ is this
and it's actually very eye-opening as as
as the
the article goes on um as it explains
not just this one christ but other
christs
and and other uh beings that have come
before him and this is all based off of
their enlightenment
um i believe so yes okay well what's
kind of alarming to me about a situation
like this
is they're saying that this christ is
going to come and he's going to bring
about this age of peace right
this peace peace peace but that's not
really what the bible describes is the
end of the world right
right it's going to get worse and worse
and worse like a woman going into labor
right that's where first thessalonians 5
talks about
you know when they say peace and safety
and sudden destruction comes upon them
as like a woman with a travail right
and they shall not escape that
end of the world scenario the world is
calling peace peace peace and then this
kind of craziness happens
so the fact that they're prepping
everybody for this
age of peace i think is just setting you
up for a false christ when they say
peace and safety you think they're
talking about the antichrist
the the atmosphere that the antichrist
will provide before sudden destruction
comes
yeah yeah i do what's what's even more
disturbing is
is the implication here because they're
well i mean let's just call it what it
is
they're not saying jesus christ which
means they mean another christ
so the implication of that is there's
another being another person and jesus
christ didn't do it right the first time
right you need somebody else to teach
you principles
and values and techniques on which the
life must be based
during whatever age so whatever jesus
did it wasn't enough
that's what we're saying at that time
and so you need somebody else but even
now because we have the account of the
bible
we have the account of everything that
he taught and by implication that's not
enough
right but that's what i'm saying is like
that's that's an interesting observation
so even here's what i thought was
interesting was that
outside of the typical christian
uh environment typical christian
atmosphere
um you know again
the losses trust was formerly or
the publishing company the lucis
publishing company
was formerly the lucifer publishing
company right
so and lucis is
is another name for light
but yet they are saying the reappearance
of the christ
is imminent so even even in 1981 when
this was first published
they knew the reappearance of the christ
is imminent um
it goes on to say this is where it was
starting
starting to really open open my eyes was
the christ
is subject to the laws of evolution
and therefore to inevitable change
and development which goes in stark
contrast
with hebrews chapter 13
verse 8 which says
christ is the same yesterday jesus
christ oh yes yes
sorry sorry let me start that over which
says jesus christ is the same
yesterday and today and forever he never
changes
forever but it says here perfection is
relative
and even our planetary logos our god
is evolving at his own cosmic level
and in relation to his responsibilities
within the solar system and the universe
so when he comes he just christ he
really doesn't have anything to offer
because he's not evolved yet
and because he's subject to evolution
there was no perfect plan there was no
there was no plan of perfection and no
plan of salvation
wow because that plan would have had to
be
so what's his purpose
hey god what's right and wrong i don't
know don't worry about it it's going to
change
yeah so so just so this holds weight
in the viewer's mind here i just want to
kind of link something real quick
this is the lucious trust
which is basically the publishing arm of
the united nations
yes so this is the united nations
that is supposedly trying to police and
get the entire world onto a one world
religion
and this is their angle
or their i mean this is one of the
things that they believe i guess you
could say
like that because it's that kind of
connection so so to be fair
i i believe that loses trust what i
understand is that the lucius trust
is completely separate correct
but they are they are a publishing arm
okay
so so is there is there significant
influence
sure because there's a lot of things
that alice a bailey who is
you know connected to this here um alice
a bailey
was writing curriculums and things that
the un is going to use for like
education
and things like that so this woman that
is is basically spelling this out right
here
is intimately intertwined in between the
you in
right are there any absolutes in this
document
i'll read on okay when he resumes his
direct contact with human affairs
so that's that's a big red flag right
there resuming his direct contact with
human affairs because when he comes back
he's just coming back to to pick up his
flock
when when he resumes his direct contact
with human affairs he will no longer be
confined to one small area of the planet
or to the con or or to the teaching
function
which seemed to be his main avenue of
service in palestine
his vision his influence and his
activities will be planetary and will
affect human
thought and activity in all the main
areas of human life
although he may well concentrate his
major attention
and energy in one or other
of the specific avenues of daily living
i bet you he's going to be like you know
he's coming back he's
he's still hanging out with the
prostitutes man he's gambling in
in vegas you know it's like they
probably have this totally different
idea of of a jesus i mean
i think yeah we don't want to make fun
but it's just not making much
sense it doesn't make much sense yes and
here and so
here's the cut the christ consciousness
that i found in the first
the first mention of christ
consciousness um or the first
first couple but it is in this sense
that we shall recognize the evolved
state of the christ
consciousness in the modern world
and it's like you said you know that
that phrase of
uh or concept of christ consciousness
that's that's being promoted now
in the mainstream uh by by new age books
by television host oprah winfrey
um eckhart tolle um
you know and and social media through
yoga
you know there's and it sounds great
like like you know if we've done a
number of shows
on the new age we've had a lot of new
age people come onto our show
and it's like you know on the surface i
could understand how if you really
aren't familiar with the bible
how does that sound bad that you want to
be you know aware of your relationship
with other people and you want to be
better and i mean those are those are
biblical concepts
but then it's just like like we had this
one
lady on our show and she said like you
know she'd communicate with these
spirits and stuff like that and they
were all you know trying to tell her how
to be better and stuff
and then the second she meant to mention
jesus christ they were like
stop talking to her and they just like
had no interest in and then they started
being mean to her
just because she mentioned jesus christ
and so you know
it's it's interesting that yeah it's
just like
oh yeah it sounds pretty on the outside
but when you really kind of
get to the nuts and bolts of it it's
really just a slam on
on who jesus really is and it is
twisting all that
and we are we're being influenced today
to to see lucifer also in
a different light uh no pun intended but
um you know that that he is being
portrayed
in the media as somebody that's hey this
this is an okay guy he's pretty cool you
know he's uh he's got his own tv show
um you know and
you know and when you come to think of
it um what's being portrayed is that he
came down to
to give us knowledge right so he
sacrificed himself he he got out of
heaven
to come down to earth to provide
knowledge to
humankind and
you know that's that's not the perfect
plan um
but there's a three-fold method of the
christ's
reappearance further along in this in
this article
there's a three-fold method of the
christ's reappearance
put in these words first he will
reappear
i'm not making this up he will reappear
by an overshadowing and telepathic
influence on the minds of prepared
disciples
and initiates this will be his primary
work on the mental plane
and the most effective method for his
spiritual interference
not intervention but interference in
world affairs
thus he will have outposts of his
consciousness
in every nation so he's coming is not
visually
based on that first he's gonna reveal
himself to
their version of the rapture yeah
telepathically yeah okay so
so people will by by this by that
statement
telepathy is being able to to hear
the voice now granted can we hear
the voice of god in our heads absolutely
um but but in this we're we are told
that telepathically he's going to
influence the minds
and have outposts all in every nation
so listen to this that i find that
fascinating because
with god satan all he can do is
literally counterfeit god
you know it's like he's not going off
and doing something totally random
separate different it's like he takes
what god is doing
and god is communicating with his people
that's what we lost in the garden of
eden right we got kicked out of the
garden of eden we we
lost this face-to-face communication
with god and so god had to find other
creative ways to still keep that
communication alive right
and so in the end of the world god's
people are going to be so connected to
god that they will be
like literally following the lamb
wherever he goes right
they hear his voice and that's why it
says in john 10 27-28 it says my sheep
will hear my voice
and i know them and they follow me and i
give unto them eternal life and they
shall never perish
neither shall any man pluck them out of
my hand
but the devil also has he's whispering
to people and people are following
his dictates so why this is so confusing
is because you can even read the bible
and be like oh wow god
god's gonna talk to me and he's gonna
he's gonna lead me around
and then you read this and they're
saying the same thing but how does he
talk to us
yes that's the important point here's
how the book of hebrews opens
god who at various times and in various
ways spoken time
past to the fathers by the prophets as
in these last days spoken to us by his
son
whom he has appointed air of all things
through whom he made the worlds
right how is he talking to us today
it's still through his word right right
it's not
it's it's not another
means we have to have something to go by
um if it doesn't line up with god's word
it would it would be chaos god's word is
the standard right because you could
have all these people claiming
yeah i'm hearing god and he's telling me
to kill you right now
you know it's like like what we've seen
in the simpsons episode with
homer and he's you know impersonating
god and telling ned flanders to
kill all these people you know the
standard is god's word
always that's what we go by and if these
other things don't line up
they're not the right thing second by
stimulating the christ
life or consciousness within the masses
of humanity
leading to a reorientation of human
desire
this involves the astral or emotional
plane
as good will is released into the hearts
of mankind they become
more disposed to create right human
relationships
which is the major objective of the
christ's triple
activity and third his physical
appearance
so establishing a potent point of
hierarchical
energy on earth in a way not previously
possible
the locale of this focal point is not
yet determined
it depends upon the effects of the first
two stages it depends also upon the
medium
he will use to implement his new purpose
whether politics
religion economics social sciences
the determining factor will be the
number the ability
and the status of the disciples active
in the chosen field
so so let me this is a very confusing
language but let me try to wrap my head
around this
is this basically saying that
that the outcome of
christ's effectiveness is literally in
the hands of the
disciples and the way that they portray
it
is that kind of what you're getting so
there will be modern day disciples
yes so based on based on the wording
uh they they will hear of they will
first the first stage is
is hearing of his coming telepathically
by the time we get to the third stage of
his of his re reappearing
he is going to be working in the state
of affairs of
of humanity of our daily lives uh
improving those those things so
whether it's politics or science or or
medical or
social social whatever whatever it is um
there will be a major improvement but it
but it's
saying that the impact really is
determined by the way that the disciples
handle it
right yeah yes so the first one is this
telepathic
communication so he's not he's not
apparent as yet he's just talking to his
believers
and then the second one which is
according to the major
out of the three is the recreation
of right human relationships which
i'd like to know what that is and then
the third one is actually his physical
appearance
which is based off of how the believers
respond to the first
too really fascinating you get down to
here and look the word relationship is
even
capitalized when it's his keynote for
the coming area
what what that speaks to me is it's all
about unity
that's what restoring all these human
relationships is about so this coming
christ
is really here to create unity
worldwide okay so now look at how this
is being set up
right the outcome of basically
everyone coming to a christ
consciousness is determined on the way
that everybody
handles this information right so if
everyone is not on that same page you
are now the problem
you are now the problem you are now the
problem and it's like we need to deal
with the problem
because it's preventing us from getting
to the christ consciousness wow what a
trip that is the element that's missing
throughout all of that is choice
so even in the bible like there's
there's a set end but there's still
two sides like you have a choice you can
determine which way you go for here it's
like until we reach this
right i'm not coming right it's like
they've already set up wow
you being the problem if you don't go
along with the program wow
yeah that's scary so let us at least
let us at least assume the possibility
of a physical person a christ working on
the world stage
to introduce the values the guidelines
and the modus
operandi of the age of aquarius
now we obviously have the values we have
the guidelines
and we have the modus operandi in the
bible
in in the word of god uh we have the
entire plan of humanity we have we have
the entire plan of salvation
uh throughout the the scriptures so
we're not in age of aquarius yet
that's what i understand so okay we're
just entering to that like we're in the
process of going to age of
aquarius and and all of this centers
around
horoscopes and astrology and all that
kind of stuff so i mean the fact that
they're blending
horoscopes astrology with jesus is
pretty new-agey
which is what alice a bailey was really
into right i mean new age
i don't know how how much of the new age
is spun
out of that or they share common so why
do you think they're using the word
christ you know if they're so not
christian why use the word christ
christ means messiah so i'm different
yeah i'm going to go out on a limb here
if it's coming from something called
lucifer
oh sorry excuse me lucious right
so he's got to prepare the way
for his final like masquerade it's going
to be of a religious order
so this is him really like doing the
ground work
i think and working through a lot of
these people
to basically prepare the team i think we
are going to see a day in age that satan
will step on the scene
humanity will see him with their
physical eyeballs
and his other angels and everything are
going to come out of the woodworks
and that's why the spiritualism is so
dangerous like all these movies are
preparing us to
i mean dude if an angel stepped on the
scene right now we'd all freak out
we'd be like daniel on the ground like
can't breathe
can't see and and now it's like with so
much priming of that stuff people won't
be so shocked anymore
and i think these guys are coming out of
the of the of the woodworks
and then you couple into that some sort
of ass
you know extraterrestrial this person
came from
way up far outer space and all that and
you blend all that together i mean
the world will eat it up so here's kind
of a blending of the of the oneness that
we also hear about in
in the new age because it goes on to say
this will mean a totally new development
in human and planetary experience there
have been avatars
in incarnation for brief periods at
several times
over the centuries so it bundles in
together
hermes krishna buddha
and the christ the christ of 2000 years
ago
there are a few of those who have
brought light
and change into the world by manifesting
an aspect
of divinity during a world period of
lawlessness
and degeneration so this is looking
ahead at a period of lawlessness
and degeneration and and basically
justifying the reappearance of the
christ because of that
because of lawlessness and and
degeneration but
the christ has now achieved a state of
spiritual
unfoldment which for the first time
permits a son of god capitalized
to manifest all three aspects of the
godhead
simultaneously now we know
the three aspects of the godhead right
so that's
god the father god the son and the holy
spirit comforter
but this is saying the three aspects of
the godhead simultaneously
light the light of the creature in
creative intelligence
unfolded in the past love
the major influence and energy wielded
by our planetary logos
for the unfoldment and manifested life
in the present
and power the power of the will to
good motivating all
logoic activity and infusing all human
souls
with the quality to be revealed in the
future
this is not the trinity of the
scriptures this is not the trinity
of god satan brought light and knowledge
to man
lucifer you know when it says here the
light of the creative intelligence
unfolded in the past
that that directs me all the way back to
the beginning where satan brought
brought light and knowledge to man
brought it
but but um you know as as the
light bearer it's interesting that they
want to aim
at good like this is leading up to
something that's going to be
good and they're going to teach you how
to be good okay
so that sounds great right but think
about all the movies that we've reviewed
on this
channel okay uh it's so good to be bad
it's so they have flipped the idea of
what is even good
this is so wrong but it feels so good
right right and it's like they're
confusing you of like people have no
discernment
it seems like uh in the world sense
and and if they're misunderstanding
actually what is good
it seems like that is a precursor
because they know that this is coming
down the road
so when they start to introduce like oh
this is good but it's like
really bad right
no totally totally it's confusion
and what is god not the author of not
confusion
that's right so this is another section
of the article that says inclusiveness
of spiritual development so it's that
it's that unity
you were talking about one of the
outstanding characteristics of all
spiritual development
is its inclusiveness no nothing of any
value
is left behind or discarded everything
of significance to the process of
evolution
is built into the consciousness so we
have already
built within us ingrained in our
consciousness
the process of evolution or the memory
bank
while only the harmful the unworthy
and the unnecessary are discarded and
left behind
having served their temporary purposes
in the duality of human experience
this means that as an individual becomes
more spiritual
more attuned to the divine principle
ensouling him
he also becomes more human a more
accurate example
of what a redeemed and enlightened human
being
is meant to be wow
is this document like are there
references is it pointing to something
else
because it's very broad like
are there specifics as to what these
things are
what uh i'm forgetting the terminology
but it's just like doing a way of
certain things
the inclusiveness right of of certain
things what are those things and
not i mean i don't know if you have the
answer but i
i don't okay um
and because because as i was reading
this it was just it was mind-boggling
and
uh i mean i practically fell on the
floor reading reading some of this
i mean just one thing that's so
beautiful about the bible there's no
like
loose ends you know you can read through
you know exactly what he's talking about
you know exactly what he's referring to
you know the guidelines like
you know there's no like i wonder what
that means or maybe maybe it means this
no this is what it definitely means and
there's cross references and all this
stuff
just a lot of holes it's it's broad
enough that
any average person might just go along
with it and say
oh yeah that sounds that sounds great as
just a concept
versus the the specifics that god gives
in the word i'm doing this for you
because
i love you i don't want you to sin
because it leads to death
um he gives us reasons for
for everything that he does and he gives
us the wise and definitions
why did you create this why why did you
send this person
look at the counterfeit that's happening
here though okay so
there's this place that they're wanting
humanity to get
to and if you don't go along with this
program
then you're actually going to be left
behind right
but look what the bible teaches there's
this place that god wants to bring
people to
and if you don't get with the program
there he's coming back to take people
home
and you're going to literally be you
don't want to be left here
when god takes the other people to
heaven right so it's like
there's this language that is so close
to what the truth
of that really is but then it's all
wrapped up in this
it's about consciousness and this like
you know it's not about
like what what the three angels message
is all about
right i mean like revelation 14
you know giving glory to god coming
out of the systems of the world not
having the character of the world
not you know um engaging in the
world deceptions that are happening i
mean that's what that whole message is
is all about
the world right but this is really kind
of the
opposite of that if you would you know
what i mean it's almost saying like
like instead of coming out you need to
come together
and if you're not part of this we're
gonna leave you
out you served your purpose in the
duality
and now you are a duelist and we need to
do away with you
for aquarian men and women he will dis
he will demonstrate
his perfected humanity in expressing the
will
and the purpose of deity symbolizing the
ability of
present day mankind to restore
and this is this is in quotations to
restore
the plan on earth
now there is something called the great
invocation i i think he may have had
that
um in a in a previous episode actually
but
so the loser's trust and in the great
invocation
uh it speaks of the i don't want to read
it because to me this is this is a spell
so to to summarize it or to read maybe a
couple
parts of it uh from the point of love
within the heart of god let love stream
forth into the hearts of men
may christ return to earth well that
sounds pretty harmless
right yeah and it sounds very very
loving
from the center which fast forward from
the center
which we call the race of men let the
plan of
love and light work out
and may it seal the door where evil
dwells
let light and so the final the final
line of this great invocation says let
light and love
and power restore the plan on earth
so what planet are they are they saying
is this the the true plane of god is
this the perfect plan
the perfect creation that he prepared or
is this is this the plan of lucifer is
this the trust
of lucifer is that plan based on
knowledge based on
you're going you're going to know more
because you now have christ's
and you're going to be a better person
because of that
you're going to you're going to receive
the light you're you're going to receive
more light yeah when you think of like
light you know i just think like
lucifer's name is light
and it's like let light land of love
and light right but it's so ambiguous
that it could fit in literally
any context or any religious context
yeah exactly
i mean do you think it's disarming it's
very disarming do you think satan loves
loves yeah that's a good question maybe
he has
different definition do you think he
loves to watch you fall
yeah yeah i mean is it possible to love
something evil probably a means to an
end right
is it possible to love something evil
yeah
like for him i love sinning you know
what i mean like can you do that well
sure
right so you can't necessarily say that
love is the
basis of the foundation you know what i
mean
you could be a drug addict and i love
drugs yeah i love the feeling that this
gives me that's not a good
like line of what is something that's
good you know what i mean right
which is a counterfeit because you know
god is love
and the order of heaven is love so
it's it's it's hard to kind of wrap your
head around
and that love is defined yeah
all right so you guys ready for this one
okay yeah contrary to popular belief
the christ is not coming to correct our
mistakes
and take care of the appalling results
of our own
separateness of and willful selfishness
he is not returning as a great religious
leader the religions of the world are
too divided
and factionalized that's true to accept
the christ's inclusiveness
and love for all mankind he is coming to
establish the principles
and values including the techniques on
which life
must be based during the aquarian age
there it is again
and to encourage the present incipient
trends towards
right relationship leading to peace on
earth
due to unfold in the coming 2000 year
cycle how delusional does that sound not
he's not coming to correct our mistakes
and take care of the appalling results
of our own
separateness and willful selfishness
and you know it's not jesus then yeah
that's right
that's why it's really important to have
a correct
relationship with jesus how do you how
do you have that relationship you've got
to spend time with him right
you've got to be able to to hear his
voice see the way that he works i
i think the story of like elijah when
he's like you know he watched fire come
down from heaven what a cool
experience to experience right my god's
more powerful than your god
um what a what a spiritual high but then
like literally i don't know what few
weeks later
maybe a month later even days later he's
running for
his life and when god speaks to him
he doesn't use this you know what i mean
he causes all these things to happen
around elijah but but
the bible keeps saying god was not in
that god was not in that and then i love
how god shows up to him he's just like
hey elijah
what are you doing you know i love it
when god asks those questions
like you know like he doesn't know come
on um
but that just shows you that you can get
to know how
god acts and how god is and how god
responds to things
and and and the better that you
understand how god acts and responds to
life and and you can see his handiwork
in
all sorts of things so you can see real
quick when it's not him
but you've got to know him to be able to
understand what that is
so anyone that really knows jesus is
going to realize
this is this is not my shepherd this is
not the right
person for me to follow that's right
he could be black brown olive yellow or
white
man or woman we do not know yet so so
they say
this reminds me of like you know that
verse the demons hear his name and
tremble
they can't identify this crisis they
can't
name him that's a great point
now here's here's something that's very
interesting that relies
on on human interaction and human action
i should say some degree of world peace
must be established as the demonstration
of a gained wisdom in human relationship
and there must be sufficient numbers of
trained serving and dedicated disciples
available to act as his cooperators and
co-workers
he will not be publicly proclaimed as
the christ
either before or after his emergence on
the world scene
and he himself will not claim that
distinction
he will work as an enlightened and
capable individual
of vision and purpose and he will be
recognized
by his own people it reminds me of
philippians 2 11 and that every tongue
shall confess that jesus christ
jesus christ is lord
to the glory of god the father the
christ will be preceded
and here's where you know we kind of
start
talking about are they talking about
jesus christ or
what what other christs you know are
they talking about
uh in in pastimes the christ will be
preceded
by certain members of the spiritual
hierarchy
members of some of the 49 ashrams who
will also help to complete the final
preparations
for his future work this phase in the
externalization process we are told
should be completed by about the year
2025.
after that we should be alert to
recognize the christ
wherever he may choose to reappear so
they're telling us
regardless regardless of of what this
article what
what this verbiage is alluding to
whether this is the antichrist or
whether it's the real christ i don't
believe that it's the real
i don't believe that it's jesus
they are saying they're giving a date of
2025.
whether that date is accurate or not
we'll see
but but it's very specific
and i think we should all be
um i think we should all be aware and be
alert
uh especially in in these end times we
have to be
um because even even they know and even
they are saying that
you need to be alert wherever he may
choose to
to reappear and that's actually and that
right there is very true because
wherever he chooses to reappear
he will reappear yes which will be above
us so
strange because at a one side of their
mouth they're saying
you don't know what nationality
you don't know male or female he's not
he or she is not going to proclaim
himself as the christ
and you're only going to know if you're
a follower so then that begs the
question like
well how am i going to know well if i'm
a follower well how to become a follower
well let us tell you
you know so you have to go through
somebody else
to really be able to figure out
if you're on the right page or not
essentially they're setting themselves
up so that you need them
yeah which is not all that different
than other systems like catholicism
right that's right because they're
interpreting
they're interpreting their their own
doctrine at that point
it says this is the christ as he is so
so again
the whole topic of this article this is
the christ as he is
not as he was 2 000 years ago
he is a world server a world spiritual
executive
involved in the complex affairs of our
contemporary society
in process of great change undergoing
the crisis crises and tensions
of a transformation in consciousness
which the christ has also experienced in
himself
so wrapping up on on this article uh
towards the end
it reads this is the true reason for for
the christ's intention to reappear
to manifest the power and the synthesis
of the one life
this will revere this will reveal
a clear distinction between material
living
and spiritual living it will become
apparent
through a widespread demonstration of
human goodwill
the lowest expression of the second ray
of love or wisdom
strengthened by the will to good of the
first ray
what yeah but
it it almost kind of sounds like jesus
is is
going to come back because we're going
to be so good
you know right where it's it's we're
going to show this demonstration of
kindness and good will
and he's going to come back for what for
what yeah what do you need him for them
we're going to recognize that the world
is in shambles
and that and that because of that
we are we are gaining knowledge and and
gaining consciousness
to then bring about the will to good
it's it's our will to to bring goodness
to the world uh um okay so i think that
this is pretty crazy
because i you see how
look how look at look at how god is
going to produce a people in the end
right so he's going to produce a people
that
are so not in love with their own lives
even unto death that they literally
have the faith in and of jesus
right the testimony of of of jesus
and and it's like they they are living
this life which is basically like what
they're saying there's gonna there's
this point that's gonna get to you
but then you hear the little tiny subtle
language of
well it's not really about moral
morality or we're not really he's not
really coming to like
teach you anything you know what i mean
so it's like here on one hand you have
the bible teaching you that that yeah
god
is god is going to have a people that
are going to represent him
what's interesting is that nowhere in
this article did it say anything about
sin it did not relate jesus to sin and
did not relate
man to sin
otherwise there would there that would
be the reason for jesus
right yeah you just need more
enlightenment like you
you want
that's all you need but no repentance
and no remission of sin
there was a second article uh very brief
but also
just as confusing because really that's
what we're talking about is is
the confusion of of truth
but it's called the jurisdiction of the
christ
and it says cycles come and go and are
in
and are an intrinsic part of the
unfolding life of humanity
periods of activity oscillate with
periods of
apparent inactivity the ebb and flow of
life is
evident all around us throughout the
long
course of human evolution greater and
lesser avatars
have appeared have led exemplary lives
of service
and have revealed those inner truths
appropriate to the age
and according to the ageless wisdom
teachings a great one
is due to appear again written more than
2 000 years ago but equally relevant
today
the profound hindu scripture the
bhagavad gita
informs us that whenever there is a
withering of the law and an uprising of
lawlessness
on all sides then i manifest myself
for the salvation of the righteous and
the destruction of such as do
evil for the firm establishing of the
law
i come to birth age after
age so that's pretty wild interesting
huh
so it's like when things get so bad
something pops up and set this on the
right path right
that's pretty pointless i mean if you
think about it
we're just stuck in this cycle of we're
going to get bad
and then something's going to come along
to correct us and then we're going to
get bad again
and then it's going to correct us and
we're going to get bad again i mean
what's the point what it says here about
alice bailey it says over 70 years ago
alice bailey suggested establishing a
united
world group given to unanimous and
simultaneous meditation
upon the work of preparing the world for
the new
order and for the jurisdiction of the
christ
so she established this in in 1922
and while i don't know
the official establishing of lucis trust
as the publishing arm of the united
nations
what can what we can be sure of is that
there has been worldwide expo
exposure to the writings of alice bailey
to the to the writings of esotericism
and and eastern mysticism and
wide exposure to to to these false
descriptions
of of the christ of a christ
um but that is but that it is not
christ as he is christ as he is has been
given to us
throughout history in in his word period
period do you know what the response has
been of the united nations
to this um what do you mean
because this publishing company you're
saying is part of
the united nations i believe it's it's
under contract so they're under contract
to be
because they're their own entity okay so
would they just be releasing things for
the united nations or
are they like publishing but there's a
lot of intertwined
things in between those systems
and you know as i'm sure the the united
nations is trying to understand
how to govern an entire world underneath
one
what's the religion look like what's the
education look like what's the
social status look like what's all these
things and
this is alarming to me that this is kind
of the building blocks
of what a lot of these guys are
believing and and aiming at
so in the religious department of that
this is what they believe crazy crazy
crazy
well thank you so much for the
diving into this and sort of dissecting
this because
um you know we've kind of approached
this type of a topic from the media
standpoint
and to kind of understand it on a sort
of political world stages
standpoint is kind of interesting um
but yeah i mean it is it is of dire
importance that we have a
relationship with christ that we
understand
who he is how he is and really
understanding how to build that
relationship through his word
because the better that you know the
bible the better that you can take
you know take your eyes up look at the
world and say hey
they're trying to push this on us but
that's not what the bible says so
you know i need to figure that out but
if you don't understand from the bible
this could potentially sound great and i
know a lot of people are going to go
with this deception
and it's not just being aware of the
truth so you can identify the deception
be prepared for the pushback that's
right for sure right
so to the viewers out there i want to
leave you with this
from mark chapter 13 verses 21 and 22
jesus says and then if any man shall say
to you
here is christ or lo he is there
do not believe him believe him not for
false christs and false prophets
shall rise and shall show signs
and wonders to seduce and if it were
possible
even the very elect he says in verse 23
i have foretold you all things
david thanks for sharing with us we hope
you guys had a blessing over today's
topic
and really we want to encourage you
really
build your relationship with jesus but
get to know the god of the bible
get to know him just read the gospels if
you don't know quite where to start
a great place to start is the gospels
read through matthew mark luke and john
and just see the way that jesus really
interacted with humanity what his
mission was all about
and from there then you can kind of um
build your understanding by jumping
around in different parts of the bible
but
we just hope and pray that this time is
coming
down the road and i feel like there's no
time left i don't know about you guys
but
you can take a look around the world
around you and it is coming apart
extremely fast so
we hope that you guys had a blessing um
share this video
like it subscribe and definitely thank
you guys for watching thank you for your
support and we'll catch you all next
friday
[Music]
you